good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock tackling the tidal wave of
omicron with a plan to get the nation
boosted
but will it be enough to stop a return
to tougher restrictions in the new year
can it be done and will it help protect
hospitals and prevent deaths the health
secretary sanji javid will be here very
shortly and we'll get labour's view
after eight with the shadow foreign
secretary david lammy we'll also speak
to the welsh health minister who says
new restrictions are likely there in the
next few weeks
[Music]
also this morning we'll hear from a
musician again using his talents to
raise funds for a young boy in need and
wishing you
a yappy christmas we'll speak to the
owner of these adorable sausage dogs who
were dressed up for a special occasion
it's monday the 13th of december
call to jab arms the prime minister sets
sites on vaccinating some one million
people a day by the end of the year in
the race to beat the new variant
no one should be in any doubt there is a
tidal wave of omicron coming
the south african president tests
positive for covid as the country
records 18 000 new cases the vast
majority thought to be omicron
desert storm mercedes to go to the
international court of appeal after max
verstappen denies lewis hamilton a
record eighth f1 world title
police miss searching for a missing
nursing assistant have found a body in
this south london park
the eye of the storm the u.s president
declares a major disaster in kentucky
after deadly tornadoes in several states
here in kentucky the governor tells sky
news that the community will be rebuilt
it will be supported as it recovers from
the most horrific tornado
i'm in the ukrainian capital as the g7
warns of massive consequences if russia
attacks
and the weather at home stormy
conditions are possible in the north
this morning but it will be mild this
week with conditions settling down
[Music]
good morning everyone a tidal wave of
omicron is how the prime minister has
described what's coming after revealing
plans to offer all adults in england a
coveted booster before the end of the
year that would mean jabbing around a
million people every single day boris
johnson said if people don't get boosted
it risks a level of hospitalization that
could overwhelm our nhs and lead to very
many deaths
the booking system opens to all adults
from wednesday with some walk-in centres
opening today for those without
appointments
42 military planned teams will help the
nhs and thousands more volunteers have
been called for
that's as the uk's coveted alert level
was raised to level four meaning direct
pressure on the nhs our political
correspondent kate mccann reports a
fortnight ago i said we would offer
every eligible adult
a booster by the end of january
today
in light of this omicron emergency i'm
bringing that target forward by a whole
month an ambitious new target to tackle
a new emergency from today all over 18s
in england will have the chance to get
their booster job before the end of the
year the target move forward by a month
because of the threat posed by omicron
no one should be in any doubt there is a
tidal wave of omicron coming and i'm
afraid it is now clear that two doses of
vaccine are simply not enough to give
the level of protection we all need
military planning teams will be brought
in across the uk to support additional
vaccine sites and mobile units while
clinics will extend their opening hours
so they're open every day of the week
the prime minister has called for an
extraordinary effort i think it's really
important to get my booster i want to
keep myself um but ultimately my family
safe as well the medical specialists say
come and get it i
follow what they say let's do that the
whole consciousness
get our mother and be careful
what more can you do
the pressure now firmly on the nhs to
deliver of course general practice uh
general practices across the country uh
are involved and lots of other allied
healthcare professionals nurses um and
volunteers pharmacies and so on so um
you know i have great faith that this
will be achievable
labor agrees
this has got to be a big national effort
all of us have got a part to play and
it's crucial that you know despite
people's anger and frustration with the
prime minister justifiable anger and
frustration with the prime minister we
put that to one side uh in the effort to
get the vaccine boost to roll out and to
make it a success the prime minister
must make decisions to protect the nhs
from omicron without all the data
decisions that will affect all of our
lives decisions that many on his back
benches will not support and those
political problems are piling up
questions about christmas parties here
in downing street
and are worried that the conservatives
could lose a key seat in a by-election
later this week
the address was about convincing the
country to support him yes
but it was about getting his parties
backing too boris johnson knows he must
prove his critics wrong this week is the
turning point a reinvigorated booster
campaign and a by-election win the price
of power kate mccann sky news
one of the busiest men in the country
joining us now the health secretary
sergeant javid hello thanks for joining
good morning
we really appreciate you taking thank
you for having me how many people a day
do you want to vaccinate how do they go
about getting the jab and will the
centers be open through christmas
well thank you again for having me the
since we learned about omicron our
strategy has been to to buy time to
assess it and to build our defenses what
we now know about omicron is that first
of all that it's spreading at a
phenomenal rate something that we've
never seen
before it's doubling every two to three
days in infections and that means we're
facing a tidal wave of infection is
we're once again in a race between the
vaccine and the virus the second thing
that we now know for sure is that the
vaccines two doses are not enough but
three doses still provide excellent
protection against symptomatic infection
and that's why the booster program has
become more important than ever we've
boosted more people than any other
country in europe already but we now
need to go on a new national mission and
that's what we're doing that's what the
prime minister announced yesterday we
are extending and opening the booster
program to all over 18 starting from
today in walk-in centers they can book
for wednesday to give them all a chance
to get their booster shot before the new
year and the way we're going to do this
is by expanding it to a level the
booster program that we've never seen
before in terms of vaccination in this
country so we're going to have even more
vaccination centers we're going to open
all vaccination centers seven days a
week for at least 12 hours a day some
for many many longer than that somewhere
even perhaps 24 hours um over over the
christmas holiday period they'll be open
every day
i'm not sure exa i don't think they're
going to open on christmas day at this
point
they'll be open the current planning is
to open them every other day million
people
well
let me tell you how we're going to do it
we'll have to look the target is huge of
course it's a huge target
the highest well the highest we've ever
achieved before with the vaccination
program is around seven hundred and
seventy thousand in a day yeah in just
in terms of vaccinations
with boosters what's years uk we've
achieved 770 000 before that's the
highest in a single day in england
before and so to
to try to boost this many people you're
going to have to even beat that every
single day now that is that is
it's a look it's a phenomenal uh target
in the final thing we want to do but it
will only work if of course we've got
the capacity there and that's why we're
building this capacity including
different types of units mobile units
and pop-up units asking gps to do more
and pharmacists to do even more we've
brought in 41 military planners covering
every region in england to help with the
logistics and the planning working with
the the all the fantastic people
we're putting we are throwing everything
at it and can i just please say this to
your viewers that please play your part
this could not be more important we need
to win this race against the growth of
this virus as i say we've never seen
this kind of growth before so please do
come forward protect yourselves your
loved ones and your community is it
because astrazeneca wasn't as good as we
initially thought and actually the
booster either pfizer or modena is
what's helping no it's i i think that
would be completely unfair astrazeneca
has played a phenomenal role in
protecting that's the accuracy so you're
saying no it's uh we remember we won the
first countries in the in the world to
start vaccinating uh that has meant that
we have slowly started we saw this over
especially over the summer we started
opening up we are still one of the most
open countries and because of the
success
of our vaccination program and
astrazeneca has played a phenomenal role
what we the difference now is is this
variant and different types of vaccines
will react in different ways but whether
it's astrazeneca you had for your first
two doses or spiser and moderna you
still need a booster shot to be
protected against this new variant how
many people are in hospital with omicron
this morning
it's around 3 000 confirmed cases uh in
england
i'm sorry i beg your pardon i
misunderstood your question um cases is
around 3000. they're in in england's
about 10 people that are confirmed in
england with omicron
how many are on ventilators
i'm i'm i don't have the answer to that
question i don't know how ill they are
in hospital how many have died
uh at this point in time i can't confirm
a death but but just can i say that with
even with the see where i'm going with
it i i absolutely do and and the key
point is that you first of all if you
remember with uh when covid first came
to our shores
it arrived in january of 2020 we didn't
have our first death since until march i
believe and the reason is because
there's always a lag between infection
and then hospitalization and then sadly
death there's always a lag and that's
what we're even in so in south africa
where this uh this variant started
earlier yeah there's been a huge number
of hospitalizations they've been
doubling that's leveled off already
though hasn't it and fewer people are
now uh finding themselves on ventilators
in south africa and even the prime
minister or the president who's sadly
been confirmed
with uh omicron um he only has mild
symptoms
well
there's a lot of talk about you this
might have it might be less severe so
milder the truth is no one knows for
sure at this point it's very difficult
to compare what's happening in south
africa to what might happen here for
example differences in the age of the
population uh the different levels and
types of immunity people have you know
how they gain that immunity but
it might well let's we can't rule it out
it might be more milder than the delta
but what the the difference that there
exists is that the growth rate is what's
different and so if it grows at such a
phenomenal rate with uh with a million
with let's say a million infections at
the current growth rate by the end of
this month even when a virus is mild a a
small percentage of people from a very
large number still can equal a high
number of hospitalizations 75 000 deaths
by may is what the london school of
hygiene and tropical medicine is
modeling um they have pre previously
done modeling um they uh forecasted in
april
that uh we would suffer post lockdown uh
predicted 75 a 750 to a thousand deaths
a day by the end of summer 2021
that actually uh resulted in something
like 71 deaths a day so how seriously
can we take their figures
well look those are their figures and
they they were modeling no it's not not
at all not all that that's their figures
they don't work for the government
they're an independent group
we will get our own uh advice from the
government's own scientists and we
listen carefully to that advice and at
the end of the day as ministers you have
to take all this into account and
understand the the trade-offs because
when you do take action like you know
we've asked people to work from home uh
from today you know this has a big
impact on people's lives it's a it's a
it's a it's it's not just a distraction
it can be really difficult for people to
to be away from the office not to have
that social interaction it can impact
their life chances so we we wouldn't
take this action lightly at all so based
on the advice that we're getting but now
also on the observed data we do have two
weeks of data where we are seeing this
phenomenal growth in infections it's
already we estimate it's around 40 of
infections in london already and and so
because of this growth rate and what we
now know of the vaccines that's why
we've announced this national mission on
the booster program let me put this to
you if i may please health secretary the
prime minister said last night put the
fear of god in us do not make the
mistake of thinking omicron can't hurt
you can't make you and your loved ones
seriously ill that's what the prime
minister said yesterday you're telling
me this morning we've only got a handful
of people in hospital with um let me
finish
with omicron um as far as you're aware
probably none of them are ventilated
certainly nobody has died we have been
aware that this uh omicron variant has
been in the uk since october so that
gives us three months of data and there
have been no deaths
well as i say the omicron has only taken
hold in the uk in the last three weeks
it's already growing at a rate of
doubling two to three times uh to every
two to three days is doubling
and we are at that rate you will have a
million infections by the end of the
month
and what that means is that even if the
severity so let's think of it this way
okay if i can explain it this way with
with with delta let's assume that of uh
all the infections around two percent of
those people end up in hospital
with omicron with omicron no no with
omicron let's assume it's half the
severity it's half the sphere that's
just half it if it's one percent of a
much larger number you still end up in a
lot of hospitalizations and and the the
what the government could do you know
there's there's a couple options here
for any government right well there
haven't been any deaths yet yes but
we've known about it being in the uk
since october well it's it's only
and there haven't been any deaths yet
what matters is when community
transmission starts and that's only been
actually probably
three weeks at most in terms of
community transmission that's what we
started to see in this country and
if the government just sort of stuck its
head in the sand and said let's just
wait and see what happens let's wait for
the deaths to happen by then it would be
too late the infections the growth rate
for the certainly the next couple weeks
would have been baked in the doubling
times for the next three or four
doubling times would have been baked in
and then you'd have me here rightly
saying why didn't you act earlier why
didn't you actually have you not learned
any of the lessons about this virus have
you not learned about how to try to
protect people from it and to take
action in advance and you would rightly
have been able to ask me those questions
okay but we've got to act early and
that's the reason to have this booster
program uh expand at the pace that we
wanted to see it and ask people to
please come forward and to protect
themselves it's the best way still to
protect us given that it's here are we
going to lift uh south africa off the
red list uh we'll keep that under review
but as as as it spreads across the
country there's obviously less and less
reason to put any country on a red list
because of omicron but we are keeping a
review okay let me talk to you about
downing street um and uh what's going on
there if i may you were too upset to
come in last week weren't you i
understand that when you were looking at
that video how are you feeling about it
now
well it's it's being investigated and
pleased it's being investigated properly
it's been properly looked at
labour demanding that the prime minister
answer questions in the commons not just
about that video but about a quiz that
he hosted as well is that something that
the government should comply with well
look i saw the photo of that quiz like
anyone else what what i can see is a
it's a virtual quiz with the prime
minister sitting at his desk but again
either prime minister
who was he talking to on the quiz i
think he's talking to some of his staff
on a virtual were they and where were
they all right i don't know
it's not i don't it's duplicitous i
don't i don't know all the details what
i can what i can see the investigation
well i can see it's a virtual quiz and
and simon case has been given a broad
remit to investigate anything that he
thinks that
should be under
any type of gathering in downing street
that should be looked at on any
particular day he wants to and so if he
wants to look at this he will that's
going to be a decision for him it's not
right i think for a minister to tell him
what he should or should not investigate
he would have seen that photo i'm sure
himself but let him do his job and it's
right that it's a cabinet secretary that
does this that's a civil servant a
senior civil servant and that's the
right way to trying to establish all the
facts but in order for that um to have
that investigation to have any
credibility it needs to report the start
of christmas doesn't it well i it
doesn't it's kicking the can down the
road well i think simon case will
determine for himself how long he needs
to to establish the facts and to look at
the evidence and i'm sure if he can
publish it sooner rather later he will
there's no reason not to
whatever the
polling has uh is poor as a direct
result of of what's been happening with
the with the prime minister um
how important is thursday's by-election
to the prime minister look every
by-election is important of course we
want to win it we're in there to fight
for every vote we're lucky we've got a
fantastic candidate neil shastri hearst
there's a he's worked to the nhs uh
he's uh he's worked in the in the in the
army and he's is a fantastic candidate
and i'm sure they
anyone in shropshire that meets him will
like him but ultimately
it's about fighting for every vote yeah
the bookies and as my dad always used to
say i've never seen a poor bookie um as
saying the lib dems are going to win
well well let's let's see what actually
how will i have on the prime minister
and
the respect that he has from the party
if he loses
any party wants to win any election
whether you're in government or not we
want to win this election we won one uh
just recently and we're going to work
hard and fight for every vote we're out
of time but let me just ask you whether
you saw lewis hamilton's race yesterday
i did not i didn't have the time i
didn't read about it i just didn't have
the time are you working on expanding
the booster program indeed are you an f1
fan uh i i'm not normally but i did
watch it last week and i really wanted
to watch it this time but you should
watch it back it's an absolute outrage
some might say not that i've got any
enclosure yeah but yeah i felt sorry for
him i'm a real fan of his and and also
by the way he's just done a fantastic
video with other formula one players
encouraging everyone to come forward and
get vaccinated good to talk to you thank
you thank you dude i know you've got a
very busy schedule today thank you and
indeed uh this side of the new year
thank you thank you appreciate it thank
you let's have a look what's happening
as far as the papers are concerned the
guardians headline pm bets on one
million jabs a day to halt the tidal
wave of omicron
omi good is what the sun is saying this
morning front of the paper as they also
lead on boris johnson's turbocharged
approach to the booster rollout
the mail describes the new plan as
ambitious
with the express conveying as sense of
emergency with their headline
and the metro reports on a
record-breaking day yesterday with just
over half a million boosters being
delivered however given the maths to
achieve the one million a day needed
this would mean almost doubling efforts
for the next 18 days
while the south african president cyril
ramaphosa is being treated for mild
symptoms of covid after testing positive
it comes as the country recorded more
than 18 000 new confirmed cases
yesterday more than three quarters are
thought to be from omicron john's
standing by for us in south africa in
johannesburg this morning hi john uh
how's he doing
uh morning k yeah he is said to be in uh
good spirits uh in uh uh this morning in
down in cape town symptoms are not too
bad we are told uh he was delivering
delivering the eulogy yesterday at the
memorial service for the
last president of the apartheid era fw
to clerk and word started to filter out
that he wasn't he wasn't feeling that
great he went and got a test tested uh
positive
and he's been put into self-isolation in
cape town he's handed over the reins of
power to his deputy and they released a
statement asking south africans to
go out get a vaccination um that has
been an issue here only about a third of
the population have been fully uh
vaccinated but
this this he is just a small part of
this huge fourth wave of infection in
this country as you said eighteen
thousand new cases registered by the
authorities yesterday but so far this
wave and the vast majority thought to be
omicron so far this wave has thought to
be is is generally proving to be
manageable at the moment most people
saying that their symptoms are mild uh
people in the hospitals say that the
number of people with the most
severe symptoms are quite small in
comparison to the previous three waves
they have very few people relatively in
icu
relatively small numbers of people on
oxygen on ventilators so at the moment
it's proving manageable for south africa
police searching for the missing nursing
assistant petraeus
have found a body in a park in south
london elena is there for us in
camberwell actually in south london
hello team elena good morning um to you
tell us more
good morning kay that's right police
were called to this park in south london
on sunday by a member of the public they
are no longer here on site but you can
see there are some tributes left for
petra and cover flowers and candles now
the body that has been recovered here
has not yet been formally identified but
miss and kova's family in the czech
republic have been notified of this
development the police said additionally
the czech minister of foreign affairs
has also tweeted that their embassy here
were notified by the british police that
the body of a missing czech citizen has
been found now at this stage the police
say that this death is being treated as
unexplained and the man who had earlier
been arrested in connection to sankova's
disappearance has been released on bail
on sunday
okay thank you
the u.s president joe biden let's talk
about him he's declared a major disaster
in kentucky after deadly tornadoes in
several states the official death tell
48
but rescue workers are still searching
through debris after what could be the
longest tornado path ever recorded in
u.s history
well our u.s correspondent mark stone
traveled to kentucky and spoke to
residents of mayfield from there he sent
this report
[Music]
in this kentucky community resilience
and faith run deep
sunday worship is at 11am every week and
it was on this day too for a
congregation who survived in a church
that's still standing
but beyond the first baptist church
mayfield is devastated
businesses
homes
destroyed
on every corner in the heart of this
town they are picking up what's left
the tornado cut a path right through the
center whipping up everything
on the corner of sixth and north street
it is all too much for elise ray
i've been through the town a couple
times and saw everything but it's it's
just
upsetting you know to know that that's
the town that you grew up in and
everything you know his memories is all
gone
the building is what's left of her local
law office and the owner is david
hargrove looks like you're still at your
desk trying to clear up and you still
got a smile on your face yeah well you
know that's resilience yeah you smile or
you cry and
don't have much time for tears you know
i've had them even the buildings which
are still standing here have lost their
roofs the tower of the historic
courthouse was toppled
it really is an overwhelming experience
here block after block such
extraordinary destruction it will take
them a very long time to recover from
this
a block away we ran into the state
governor
a lot of people need a lot of help we've
seen we've seen so many different
communities that they're really
struggling now we again we open our
homes for each other we're going to make
sure that that we're fed and we're going
to rebuild we're going to make it but
we're grieving people today thank you
the rebuild he's pledged will take time
it will cost money and all of this will
stir the fractured politics here too
on the edge of the town beyond the
roadblock the cost of it all in lives
the candle factory was where for two
days and two nights now they've been
searching for survivors more than a
hundred people were working the night
shift here on friday hour by hour good
news seems less probable
[Music]
at the church they're carried by faith
but they will need more than that
the help was promised it will come but
for now this is very much a community
struggle
mark stone sky news
in mayfield kentucky
and of course we will continue to
monitor that uh for you meantime let's
take you into the eye of the storm now
have a look um at these
pictures now
wow it looks black to start with doesn't
it and then there's a lightning bolt and
you can see can you imagine if you were
on your porch
and you saw this
coming towards you and you didn't have a
basement in your house what do you do
next
sadly some people um have lost their
lives as a result of this storm heading
there oh my goodness me
that would put the fear of god in you
wouldn't you um let's meet let's tell
you about meteorologists saying it could
be one of the largest tornadoes in u.s
history at the chef jose andres has also
mobilized a team of food trucks to
support those who have been affected
and we have some of the food trucks
already
on their way there
they should be arriving in the
early hours of sunday
and i'm gonna be joining uh the teams
tonight
to make sure that
you know
we show solidarity with the many
people that during these holidays this
christmas season unfortunately they're
gonna be going for a very hard time on
top of everything else going on with
kovic
so i will report more once i'm there but
i always said that whatever there is
a fight so
hungry people and people in need may eat
that we will be there
oh thoughts with those families out
there just at the moment and the search
and rescue operation is continuing we'll
update you throughout the course of the
day here on sky news quick look at the
weather here
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
after a very windy weekend the weather
shows signs of settling down in the week
ahead and it remains on the mild side
stormy conditions are possible in
northwest scotland and the northern
isles this morning with a risk of
coastal gusts briefly exceeding 90 miles
an hour along with some squally showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now have a look at some of these images
that we've got for you this morning this
is from the greek capital in athens
as we all know there is only one santa
claus but that's never stops people
dressing up just like him hundreds did
so in the greek capital for a festive
fun run all to raise money for charity
they made their way around the two
kilometer course which included some of
the scenic sites of athens including the
olympic
athletic center there was beautiful
weather for it as you can see they were
running in a wonderfully mild 18 degrees
a lot warmer than where the real santa
claus lives of course
do you recognize who this is have a look
oh okay we're doing them full frame
there you go do you know who that is
yeah there you go it is eddie redmayne
this morning reviewing the classic
candor and ebb musical in which mr
redmayne has the look of a cherub gone
to seed the revival received four stars
out of five from critics
also from the times meet the women with
the world's largest collection of harry
potter memorabilia
health secretary has confirmed to us
that around 10 people have been
hospitalized in england with the omicron
variant 10. sanji javid says we're in a
race between the vaccine and the virus
as the booster program is expanded to
all adults but mr javid was unable to
confirm whether anyone had died from the
omicron variant or indeed if they were
on a ventilator
in england about 10 people that are
confirmed in england with omicron
how many are on ventilators
uh i'm i'm i don't have the answer to
that question i don't know how ill they
are in hospital how many have died
uh at this point in time i can't confirm
a death but but just can i say that with
even with the see where i'm going with
it i i absolutely do and and the key
point is that you first of all if you
remember with uh when covert first came
to our shores
uh it arrived in january of 2020 we
didn't have our first death since until
march i believe and the reason is
because there is always a lag between
infection and then hospitalization and
then sadly death
ali is here um i suppose some of our
viewers might be a bit surprised by
those numbers this morning first time
we've had um numbers about the impact of
omicron yeah that's right so he's very
stark on how quickly it's spreading he
said it's like something we've never
seen before but as you say he confirmed
ten hospitalizations and that he wasn't
aware of any deaths yet but he said that
the government had to learn from the
lessons of the past and it would be that
is why they are acting now he said it'd
be wrong not to do that but i think the
challenge is also going to be getting
people on board with this and he said
himself that people have a part to play
too in the booster rollout but we know
it's been a really difficult few weeks
for the government dogged by those
accusations about christmas parties and
you rightly asked him about that today
and he pointed to the simon casey
cabinet secretary investigation which is
quite an easy line for the government to
take you asked him why when that's going
to come back is it going to come back
before christmas which i think is what a
lot of people want to see he said
hopefully sooner rather than later i
think a lot of people are going to be
looking to that by-election on thursday
which he said they're working hard on
but as you put it a lot of the polls are
not particularly favorable for what is a
tory heartland seat a rock-solid
conservative majority so if they lose
that that would be very pokey say they
will if they do to the lib dems we don't
know yet um we'll find out by friday
morning if they do what impact will that
have on the prime minister they're
gathering aren't they i think that will
be a huge upset in a by-election if that
did happen i still think that's not
necessarily
what will happen
but as you say the bookies are saying
that the lib devs are creeping in and we
are seeing a real angle on the back
benches we have a vote tomorrow on the
covid restrictions and we think about 70
or so back benchers could rebel on that
the biggest back bench rebellion since
boris johnson has been prime minister so
people are circling and i think this is
a transactional relationship they know
that boris johnson does well at the
ballot box if he doesn't prove that that
is still the case on thursday then
people are really going to stop the
revenge potentially of theresa may we'll
talk about that in your take at nine
o'clock thanks so much indeed ellie for
now thank you let's take a look at the
latest covid data should we look
something like this
forty eight thousand eight hundred and
fifty four new cases of covered 19
recorded in the last 24 hours another 52
deaths have sadly been reported within
28 days of a positive test that brings
the total number of deaths in the uk
to 146
4439
to the vaccine rollout more than 25 000
people received their first dose of a
vaccine 36 000 have had their second
dose that means the total number of
people to have received their second
dose 46.7
million
uh and more than half a million people
have received their booster
that's their third vaccine and that's in
the last 24 hours bringing the total to
more than 23 million but does that need
to increase to more than a million
people a day in order to get as many
people as the government wants boosted
by the end of the year as possible it's
going to have to be a million people a
day they have mobilized the army will
that be enough he also said that all of
the vaccine centers will be open on
every day apart from christmas day he
said
vaccine passes become law in northern
ireland today they'll be needed for
entry into pubs licensed restaurants and
other venues in scotland new
self-isolation rules have come into
effect and the welsh health minister
says new covert restrictions are likely
to be introduced to curb the spread of
the new omicron variant
the welsh health minister uh joining us
now baroness morgan of course hello to
baroness thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning how concerned are
you in wales about the omicron
variant how many people are in hospital
in uh welch hospitals this morning as a
result of omicron
well thankfully we're still at the very
beginning of this wave in wales we only
have 15 cases
and uh but clearly we know that there is
a huge tidal wave coming towards us and
we're doing all we can to prepare for it
obviously by trying to get as many
boosters into people's arms as quickly
as possible
we've got a huge program on now to try
and make sure that we can deliver
as many uh vaccinations as possible that
booster we know
two vaccinations is not enough that you
do need to boost a dose and that's why
we're asking people to step forward to
understand the seriousness of the
situation
what does that tsunami look like what
what is it that we're most concerned
about
well it really is a case of numbers uh
so we're expecting uh the wave to to
reach his peak uh probably mid to late
january uh and that's why what we're
trying to do is to make sure that we can
get as many boosters into people's arms
before it hits
that's going to be a really difficult
task and our teams have been working all
weekend to see how quickly we can roll
out that booster program uh we've we've
already got plans to
vaccinate 1.3 million additional people
but the question is can we roll that
forward now and
see if we can give that protection as
soon as we can
we are very thankful to the scientists
in south africa for discovering the
omicron variant they are telling us that
it looks on balance as though it is much
milder than the delta variant fewer
people finding themselves
on ventilators in hospital fewer deaths
as a result of the omicron variant
what's the situation in welch hospitals
how many people are in hospital
well we've only we've got one case in
hospital but
we are expecting this to change very
quickly
what we're concerned about really is is
the numbers so if we see a situation
where we literally have hundreds of
thousands of people who are ill from
the omicron variants it doesn't mean
that they're necessarily very seriously
ill but the numbers of people who will
be off work will bring real pressure on
our public services in particular of
course our nhs at a time when the nhs is
stretched to its limit already and then
of course you only need a few people if
you've got vast numbers of people uh
i'm sorry to interrupt we only have a
limited period of time so you're not
concerned necessarily about the number
of deaths you're more concerned about
people being off work ill and as a
result the impact that that is going to
have on the services
no proportionately we still looking at
the data in terms of
whether people get seriously ill with us
but if a a small number of people
getting very sick from a large number of
people with omicron means that you can
fill your hospitals up pretty quickly
thank you very much indeed for the
clarification much appreciated thank you
let's talk about russia and ukraine
tensions simmering there as satellite
photos show more and more russian troops
gathering at the ukrainian border let's
uh talk about it in more detail with our
security and defense editor deborah
haynes who is in the capital kiev hello
to you deborah uh good morning um this
is getting very tense
well it is a sign of the concern being
felt by western allies you had that
meeting of the group of seven uh
developed economies over the weekend
their foreign ministers and they decided
to issue a separate statement purely
focused on the ukraine issue warning of
these massive consequences and severe
costs for russia should an invasion
happen well here in kiev yes they are
worried about the potential of all these
tens of thousands of troops amassing at
their border launching some kind of new
military attack but they're also
suspicious that actually maybe the
intent of vladimir putin is to use his
military forces as a way to gain
leverage with the west for diplomatic
discussions that would then
allow
him to have international recognition
for territory that he's already taken so
tense times and i guess the next few
weeks we'll see which way this is going
to go
hey deborah thank you thanks a lot
from today the government is advising
that all who are able to work from home
should do so as scientists fear a wave
of omicron will hit the uk but what does
this mean for businesses especially
those that rely on workers heading to
offices around the country well let's
speak now to beatrice palester who owns
juju's cafe in birmingham hello to you
thanks for joining us how worried are
you about people working from home what
impact will it have on your business
um honestly already after the
announcement the morning after we lost a
quarter of our uh christmas
uh bookings so they were mainly
corporate bookings obviously people that
aren't going to be in the office anymore
um and it was absolutely heartbreaking
it's devastating because all of our
ingredients are
you know ordered we've paid for all of
our turkeys up front and so they're
coming whether
our guests come or not so we're in quite
a tricky spot at the moment
um what can you do
where do you go from here
well we're rallying around um all of our
regular customers who live nearby are
coming for a turkey roast
which is great and we're trying to fill
the bookings but i mean at the end of
the day
um we've got to accept that there is
going to be some kind of a loss in uh
you know the part of the year when we
should be making enough to cover the
first quarter of next year which is
notoriously difficult in hospitality so
we'll just have to
try our hardest and cross our fingers
hopefully we'll pull through
it's been so challenging hasn't it just
over the last 18 months or so what would
you like to say to the government this
morning
um
i think they need to be consistent with
their messaging um
there should be one rule you know for
everyone and we've heard rumors about
parties etc and downing street and for
me you know potentially facing the loss
of my livelihood
um you know i've worked here since i was
13 years old with my mom i've known my
staff for over 10 years
um
so yeah it would just be absolutely
heartbreaking if if this was to be the
end of us
um and yeah i'm pretty angry i
understand the need for the new
restrictions but um
i just think
that the message of saying you know do
go to your christmas party but don't go
to your office
um yeah it's quite contradictory
and so i just hope that if there is
another lockdown or anything else coming
there would be more financial support
for businesses like us
okay it's good to talk to you um fingers
crossed um that um
this will be more or less the end of it
and you can start to pick up again next
year
thanks a lot beatrice thank you
thank thank you thanks let's speak to
the owner of anita caba taxi firm in
plymouth and exeter that's david
mcintosh hi david thank you very much
indeed for joining us have you been
impacted
well we've got to look at options now of
uh
possibly allowing people to work from
home uh we're very telephone oriented
we've we've got a booking app like most
companies have but sam we are looking at
introducing new training for for people
the problem we've got is you've got a
local authority down here who are
actively
engaging with people who are advertising
on social media
providing taxi services which is totally
illegal
uh they're not insured and it does
present a serious public safety problem
uh you've also got the obscene and
abusive language that of telephone
operators are subjected to now i don't
want someone being at home with their
children in the background hearing that
sort of language being used um we do our
best
we get as many attacks as we can as you
know there's a national shortage of
drivers
um so we do what we can when we can you
know but the amount of abuse that our
staff are receiving is just
unbelievable it really is disgraceful
i'm guessing that's the level of
frustration uh from people who are
trying to get a cab um and can't
how difficult is it to retain drivers
we like we've had to do things like
introduce incentive schemes for drivers
not something we were going to do anyway
but it's brought you forward um
it's it's the way you treat the drivers
drugs are treated well they stay good
drivers don't normally move offices
so we try and make sure that we look
after our people very very well
and that encourages them to stay the
biggest problem we got at the moment is
is the recruitment um we work very
closely with several of the job centres
around the area
and a lot of good people because of the
pandemic have lost their job through no
fault of their own
and they're looking for another income
so we're encouraging people to
look at taxing as an option it is a good
job uh if it's done well
and what would your message be to the
government this morning dave
i think they've got to be consistent i
mean the poor lady in front of me on
before me just now with a restaurant you
know it's actually an affects the whole
hospitality industry because people have
got to get there and get home
so i'm sure that some of her bookings
were down because the lack of drivers
means that people aren't confident going
out in the evening
and getting a taxi home at the end of
the night so it either means someone
goes as a
designated driver for the for the
evening which affects their their nice
night
um or they don't go out at all and i
think a lot of hospitality place pubs
clubs
um restaurants are finding the bookings
are down purely and simply because
people are frustrated because of the
lack of opportunity to get a taxi home
at the end of the night
okay um dave good luck it's a
challenging time i i understand we
appreciate you taking the time to join
us this morning thank you
you're welcome thanks very much
thanks a lot
um coming up on the program we're going
to be having more on the plan to get
boosters into the arms of eligible
adults by the end of the year i was
pressing actually the health secretary
this morning to ask him how many people
a day need to be vaccinated in order to
get those boosters up to where they need
to be by the end of the year he didn't
want to be pushed on that but i our
calculation is that it's about a million
people a day we're not at that now but
he did say that walk-in centers will be
open for everyone from tomorrow um and
that those walk-in centers and other
ways of getting your job will be open
every single day between now and the end
of the year apart from christmas day i
asked him how many people are in
hospital with omicron how many are on
ventilators how many have died stay
tuned and find out
you